all right good afternoon
um
it is so great to be able to talk to
people and see their actual faces such a
great thing virtual presentations really
i'm tired of virtual presentations so
this is great i'm so happy that you're
able to join me this afternoon
i'm going to talk to you about work that
i did at yahoo and how we use tls to
inject security into cross-cloud
workflows
a little bit about me folks are
trickling i am a member of the apache
software foundation
i have been a traffic server apache
traffic server committer for a number of
years
until recently i worked at yahoo verizon
media oath we've had a number of names
and i worked on the edge team wearing an
edge shirt here
more recently i have moved over to
aviatrix which is a multi-cloud
networking platform company really
fascinating stuff talk to me afterwards
if you're interested but the point of
today's talk is the work that i did at
yahoo
and in my free time i practice and teach
yoga and take yoga pictures in scenic
locations as one does
so the goal of this talk is i said to
present how we use tls
to move
yahoo's workflows from a single on-prem
deployment
into multi-cloud and hybrid cloud
scenarios
and how we did it leveraging open source
and as with any non-trivial project this
was not my work alone by any stretch of
the imagination
there was a goodly number of my
colleagues from yahoo and members of the
other open source communities and so
we'll list a few of them there
let me first start by introducing the
open source projects that we leverage so
one of them is apache traffic server
which is a project near and dear to my
heart
it is a web caching and proxying server
it's been open source for over 10 years
it was originally inktomi proxy
inktomy got bought by yahoo and yahoo
open sourced that project the
interesting thing about apache traffic
server is that it has a plug-in
architecture
so the
deployers of the traffic server can
build plugins that get registered and
get called at key points in an http
transaction process
so this is a good way of injecting
business
critical
specific logic into your http processing
i in the last four probably four to five
years now
added fine grade tls configuration tls
processing to support the work that
we're talking about today
the other open source project that we'll
be talking about and that we leveraged
is athens which is another
open source project that was
contributed by yahoo this one's a newer
one
it is a
our back a role-based access control
system that takes advantage of tls
mutual authentication
and it's been the basis for
yahoo's
service to service authentication
everything has moved over to athens and
so by using athens and traffic server
we're able to
perform what i'm going to talk about
today
so what's the motivation uh other than
this is really cool technology what is
the business case that we're solving
here
so to answer that i'm going to do a
little history lesson i decided my user
agents should be happy dancing user
agents for this presentation so we've
got happy dancing user agents
in the good old days we would have
everything would be in an on-prem
corporate data center
and maybe there would be multiple
corporate data centers but everything is
in the data center
so when the user decides to talk to
finance.yahoo.com
you ask the dns the dns points them at a
particular data center comes in the
front end maybe multiple services are
talking to each other but they're all
within the same data center
pretty straightforward good old days
were pretty easy
even in that scenario we would have
maybe caching
cdns adms having pods that are closer to
the end user so maybe we would have an
edge pod in st louis so that might cus
the user who's talking to yahoo finance
maybe would first connect to the edge
pod in st louis maybe the data's cached
there maybe not and eventually go on
over to the corporate data center in
buffalo probably
but even with that complication
everything is pretty static right there
is the edge maybe you're bringing up new
edges but it's constant software
everything that's deployed in the data
center is staying in the data center
in the more recent past we have public
clouds and our keynote this morning was
talking about public clouds
and in that scenario
for newer companies greenfield buildouts
you would just
rent resources within the public cloud
so for example aws
you would build out your
front-end back-end services within aws
and then your user agent asking for
startup.com would get directed to an aws
elastic ip address
which would go get routed to the front
end and again everything would be within
aws single cloud
so that
is great for startups for anyone that's
greenfield
but when you have a larger organization
like yahoo they're not just going to
pick up everything and throw it into the
cloud
that's probably maybe not ever do that
but certainly not i'll do that in one
fell swoop so you end up with a hybrid
cloud or a multi-cloud situation
and so in that case it's really not much
different for our end users they talk to
dns they get an address for something
and it might route them to an on-prem
server it might route them to azure
but they go and they make the request to
that front end
but then here's where things differ
right the back ends may talk to services
in other clouds right not everything's
on-prem not everything's in the same
cloud
but our
on-prem may
talk to a service in aws
maybe our azure talks to a service in
aws maybe that service is in aws today
but maybe tomorrow it gets moved to
google cloud because we got a really
good deal with google cloud
so we have a very dynamic environment a
very dynamic trust environment
so longer can we make which was probably
bad assumptions that anything that's a
corporate ip or anything that's in our
ip space is trusted certainly cannot do
that
um
you also have to deal with historical
applications right so in the first two
scenarios we had stuff that was on-prem
probably been on-prem forever or a new
build out in aws
but here we're talking about moving
applications from on-prem into the cloud
in a hybrid cloud case
or maybe between clouds
and if you are a company that's been
around a long time you have applications
like i call here historical applications
that
are making money they're important
they're business critical
but
no one really understands how they work
you can figure out how they work of
course because it's code you can figure
it out but in terms of quickly and
agilely
augmenting them to become
aware of dynamic trust relationships
that's something that's not going to
happen
so dynamic trust relationships dealing
with historical
applications that is the problem that we
are facing
and we addressed it by adding to our
secure edge
so we've had a secure edge within yahoo
for a goodly number of years so an adn a
cdn
the secure edge is the point where the
customer comes into yahoo's corporate
environment historically
and so that is kind of the front-facing
view that presents all the latest
greatest protocols
it
runs apache traffic server it verifies
that the security is good that the
headers are good it just that first pass
of making sure that really obvious
malicious traffic does not make its way
through
and that it's the one stop shop for our
security team to start to verify that
we're all running the appropriate
versions of openssl we're offering the
right
ciphers
that everything is good in our
presentation to the customer
so this seemed like a reasonable point
to add in addition to presenting
and proxy and communication from our end
user to also use that to proxy
communication between clouds so the
client in one cloud or on-prem and the
server in the other
and that's what we did
so yes
so the goal is to move our applications
without set up a scenario where we can
move our applications without
significant security rework
so let me take a little bit of time and
review
some tls
and
talk about mtls a little bit
so in the classic tls authentication
it's an asymmetric authentication right
only the client only the server provides
authentication information to the client
so in this scenario our client
sends a hello pls low the server sends
back a hello and sends its cert
the client checks the cert
at a minimum
minimum it should verify that the cert
is signed by a trusted ca trusted
certificate authority maybe it checks
something about the names in the cert
compared to what it requested
assuming that passes then we do the key
exchange and in the course of the key
exchange the server is proving to the
client that it owns the corresponding
private key that was in corresponds to
the server cert
so again only the server proves the
identity if the client needs to prove
the identity that's done at a different
level
so maybe add a using a password at the
application
layer
but that is not intrinsic to the tls
protocol the tls protocol does allow
mutual tls or cert authentication in
both directions
so this that's what this scenario is
showing in this case the client sends a
hello the server sends it's hello and
the cert and in addition it sends a
message saying hey you should give me a
cert as well
the client checks the server servers
before and sends the client cert so both
sides check each other's cert making
sure it's signed maybe doing some
structural checks on the contents of the
cert
assuming they both pass they do the key
negotiation key exchange and in the
process of that
prove to each other that they own the
private key that corresponds to the cert
they exchanged
so this is not something that you
probably want to unleash on the end user
kind of awkward but it is a pretty good
solution for service authentication
and that is again what athens
built its role-based access control on
top of
so i talked about dealing with
historical codes historical clients
servers
it's possible that the clients
don't really
aren't capable of doing mutual tls
maybe it's the software set they're
using
it would involve some rewrite to deal
with that so we can deal with that by
putting a proxy in front of the client
the client the proxy then would take it
take care of offering the appropriate
certs
when the server asks for a client cert
and when we started this traffic server
you could configure one
cert that you're going to offer up if
the server requested a client cert
and
we've augmented that so that we can
do a finer grain certificate client
certificate selection
within traffic server the core one of
the core configuration files is the the
remap file or the mapping file
and that's the place that says for this
client request we want to send it to
this server url
and as a part of that we can provide
overloads or overrides so specifically
here we're showing
if the
client request comes in on
bank.yahoo.com
we are going to override the
ssl client cert file name to be pci.pem
and if the client comes in on yahoo.com
we are instead going to offer up the
cert that's in datastore.com so it gives
us that fine granularity
so a proxy can offer different client
certs to different servers
you have a similar issue on the server
maybe you have a server that's incapable
of doing mtls
so again you can put a proxy in front of
that
now this is a little trickier because
it would be easy enough to set up our
proxy to say always request a client
cert
that's easy to do
but what if
your proxy is serving requests from end
users and from services and only some of
the requests
require a client certificate
well we can't use our remap approach
because this is done before any
hdp crest is sent right this is done as
we are negotiating in that initial tls
connection from the client
so
we
take advantage of s sni
we do have sni which is server name
indication so in our client hello
there's an sni field which generally is
set to the host that the client intends
to connect to
and all modern clients do this your
browsers do this curl does this
old tv sets don't and some load
balancers stop but modern clients do
send in s and i
and so
with our first packet we can look at the
s i and we can say okay well based on
this s i
you know sni request server secure.com i
want a client cert
maybe other domains i know they don't
support http 2 very well so i'm going to
adjust my alpn and say i'm only going to
do hp one to you
so very handy
to take a look at that sni and we have a
whole sni dot yaml config to adjust
these different parameters based on the
sni name that is received from the
client
so great
the end of talk we're all done
right yeah no
problem is sni isn't really a secure
field right
it's showing up in client hello it's in
the clear
the client can set whatever sni name he
wants to set it's really this convention
that's the domain name he wants to talk
to
so it'd be easy enough for a malicious
client to set
the s i name to some other value
so if our malicious client knew that we
were using sni to set our security
policy to determine that we need a
client cert
so example we have a
policy that says
any requests for secure.com need to
provide a client cert it would be
trivial for a malicious user to instead
set an sni to insecure.com
there's no policy for that we do the
handy the tls
negotiation
no client search is requested and life
is great
and then they send the request for
secure.com
so we've had this this break we've done
our we're doing our we're conflating
what's happening in tls land with what's
happening in http
so unless we come back and check that
if we just merely move along
independently our server would just
return the sensitive information from
secure.com
and uh be pretty easily tricked right
and this is trivial this is not a super
hacker kind of move this is the curl
command to do exactly that right
you set the host header
the sni name is pulled from the url
there you go
well that's a bummer right so what can
we do
there's a couple options the first
option is say well that was really
stupid to use sni not secure just give
up on that and we'll have one proxy set
up for things that require client certs
and another one for things that don't
and we'll adjust our dns and we'll deal
with it
so that would work of course
it's a little awkward but it would work
the other option is to say well i said
the issue is that we're
doing checks across levels right across
tls and across http and we're not
bringing them back together so let's
bring them back together
so option two says for every transaction
we should check to see that the host
header value
is equal to the s and i value and if it
isn't then we should return a 403 or
some sort of error code that would be
safe right
and that would enforce
our assumption that those two values are
consistent
but that is probably too onerous
specifically in the browser case
and if the
there was no s i policy for any of the
names involved then it really doesn't
it's
over errors right
so here in a i show a browser and a
server
and the browser negotiates with foo.com
does a tls handshake because there's no
policy for free.com so no no client cert
does a request for food.com gets a
response and then reuses that connection
later
because the cert
also contains bar.com and makes a
request for bar.com
so for checking that every single
request
um has a host header that matches the
sni name then we would have to reject
bar.com even though there was no sni
policy for free.com or bar.com so
and that definitely happens so we can't
do that either so what we ended up doing
in yahoo with traffic server
is
probably what you would think if you
take half a moment right
we negotiate we get a request
we then take the host header once we get
the request and say was our security
policy associated with the value of the
host header in this case secure.com
and in our scenario yes there was
if there was a security policy or an sni
policy associated with secure.com then
we need to do the name check if there
wasn't we don't care merely we would
move along so in this case our malicious
user would get caught because there was
a policy an si policy associated with
secure.com
the names don't match with the sni
policy we would return a 403.
and this has worked very well for us we
get very few false positive errors
and we we catch our malicious users who
are trying to evade policy
there are some other options
and there's a draft rfc here that talks
about them in detail
but the idea here is that we really
should be doing this at the http layer
this kind of cheating and reaching down
to the lawyer before is a little dicey
you can actually do this for htv one so
with http one
there is one request going on at a time
over the connection
and with renegotiation in openssl we can
go and request a new client cert after
the connection has been established so
in this case we have our example with an
sni with insecure.com handshake then
getting a request for secure.com
and at that point we could go and
request a client cert for secure.com and
if they brought it then it would be
great and we could move on so that works
for hp1 does not work for http 2
because with http 2 you can have
multiple simultaneous active
transactions over your tls connection
so if you're doing this one off
request for the next client cert well
which transaction did that belong to
right
just not something that's going to work
unless you bring in some cert requesting
logic into the http 2 layer which is
what that rfc is suggesting
and so if they come through with that if
they agree on it and it gets implemented
and deployed that is probably a better
solution but in the meantime the
solution that i outlined has worked
pretty well for us
so that's kind of the basis of the
tls kind of things that we're doing
so how are we using that to build our
proxy tls
so as i said before the goal is to
support
dynamic trust relationships where the
client is in one cloud and the server is
in another cloud
so we don't want to directly expose our
servers to the internet so we have this
kind of secure edge
idea
and
as we noted before there
some client server implementations may
have some issues that we need to kind of
fix up for them so we don't want to
directly expose them to the outside
world
so there are three options there's tls
delegation
tunneling and bridging and we'll talk
through each of those
before i go into the tls delegation let
me talk a bit more about how athens
performs its authentication and
authorization so as i've said now
several times athens builds on top of
tls mutual authentication
so the client again provides a 509 cert
that's signed by the athens ca
the
valid cert
also contains a athens principle
then after the connection is set up each
request will come in with an athens
token
and the token identifies the principle
and the roles that principle is
authorized for
and so that would have been
fetched at the point of the this the
client request would have talked to the
athens infrastructure and gotten a token
to pass along
the token has a limited lifetime and
it's signed and as i noted passed in the
head of the client request
so in the athens case for tls delegation
the client is going to talk to the proxy
and the proxy will send back a proxy
server cert it's going to request a
client cert
and so the client will send its ath
insert up the proxy then is going to
perform an authorization check over the
client cert
so it's going to verify that the
cert is signed by the athen ca
assuming it is we're going to go ahead
and complete the handshake and the
client will send a request
the request will contain an athens token
a
and then the proxy is going to do
another
authentication check against the client
cert and a
so it's going to verify that the
principal and the
token matches the principle that was in
the client cert
and it's going to verify that the token
is
well formed so it's not expired and it's
signed correctly assuming that all pans
out then it's going to turn around and
make a connection to the server
server is going to send insert down the
proxy is going to send a proxy client
cert so it can't send the original
client seared up because the proxy does
not know the private key of the client
cert
so it's sending up a
new
search telling the server that hey i'm
the proxy
and the proxy sorry the server will do a
verification on the proxy client cert
verifying that it's signed by athens
assuming that finishes out we complete
the handshake and the
proxy is going to go ahead and send the
request up with the original token and a
new
header that indicates that it has
validated the token
and then the server will do a second f2
prime verifying the proxy client cert
the token and the validation header and
assuming that all checks out we'll send
the response the response will go back
to the client
so
with this the server has delegated
authentication of the
client's ath insert to the proxy
so what happens
if
the
malicious user decides well hey
maybe it's a bit an easier idea if i can
get around and pretend i'm the proxy is
that going to make life easier for it
so there's several things that uh
make it
more difficult for the malicious user to
bypass things so if i'm the malicious
user i'm pretending to be the proxy to
try to negotiate to the server
i'm going to send up my malicious cert
and i need that malicious cert to pass
the check that the server is going to
make so i need to make sure that it's
signed by a trusted
ca with the ca the server trusts
if the server is set up just to trust
our athen ca then that should be pretty
good our malicious user could possibly
uh steal a proxy cert from someplace
else but that's another issue
if our server is misconfigured and it
has too many trusted routes maybe it
trusts you know the standard linux set
of cert so digicert then it would just
be an issue for our melissa fuser to
spend 50 bucks and get a digit cert that
would
pass signature verification
so don't do that make sure that your
server is trusting a limited set of cas
so hopefully we get knocked out in our
first check there but if we move on then
the malicious user could make a request
with a token and a verification header
it will probably have to have stolen a
token because again the tokens are
signed and their limited life span so
even if a stolen shouldn't last for very
long so anyway
there are two levels of
making life difficult for a malicious
user here
so that's delegation the other
option that we have is tls tunnel
which isn't really proxying
it's really just routing but the
motivation here is that there are
certain
requests
that
for example that are supporting pci or
sox compliance that really we do not
want to terminate on our edge
because that means that we would have to
go through and do
pci
compliance checks on our edge and that
seems like a really unwise thing to do
so in that case we can set up our sni
policy to say for supersensitive
example.com just route all the
connections to
supersensitiveorigin.example.com
and so in that case
the proxy is just moving the tunneling
packets that's the tls packets from the
client to the server
not doing any checks
so not a super satisfying solution but
something that gets things going
one of the issues there is that we don't
have any control of the quality of the
tls connection between the client and
the server we're just blindly moving
things along
if we wanted to avoid decryption on the
proxy but we wanted to make some
guarantees of the strength of the
connection between the clouds then the
tls bridge solution would work
the idea with the tls bridge
is that
the request comes in kind of it's
labeled ingress but as we're leaving one
cloud
and we have a plug-in that's set up to
recognize that the client is going out
to a
server that's in another cloud
and so the plug-in will will stop that
using
one of the transaction hooks
and negotiate a new tls tunnel with a
pier in the other cloud
and with this tunnel we have control
over
using mutual tls having a strong cipher
making sure that everything is good
after that tunnel is set up then the
ingress ats will again blindly take the
packets from the client pass them along
our new tls tunnel they'll pop out the
other end at the pier ats and get sent
to the service and ditto traffic going
back
so we are probably double encrypting the
traffic that's going across the
untrusted cloud but we are sure of the
strength of the traffic
this is just another diagram explaining
the same thing in a different way so
we'll move
on so wrapping up
the secure edge approach
using the secure edge to inject
tls mutual authentication has been
instrumental in yahoo's move to a hybrid
cloud
this proxy provides our one place to
ensure that our security policy is
applied consistently
we can use the proxy to help
move forward our historical applications
more quickly so not everyone has to
become mutual tls
experts right away
and if we set things up correctly on our
ingress and egress edges
moving clients and servers between
clouds
and having the dynamic
trust authentication the athens
authentication happen
should
be much less of an issue
and i think i must have tucked really
fast
because that's all i got
are there any questions
[Applause]
yeah
so certainly one can do this at
different levels and
yeah yeah who has a uh
how to phrase that um
they like to kind of do things with
chewing gum and uh string right
uh so so doing it as a transport layer
was kind of convenient because we
already had this transport layer
infrastructure set up with our edge the
other way that you could certainly do
things is going down a layer and either
buying
doing ip secular stuff and actually
interestingly enough at my new company
aviatrix we were working at that ip6
layer wireguard layer so
that is certainly a different approach a
reasonably valid approach
you would still have to deal with the
authentication
uh so that would just deal with the
encryption um
depending on what kind of ipsec you're
using you could maybe get your
authentication at that layer too
but that would be something that you
would have to think through so yeah
certainly could do this at at a lower
layer if you're doing a historically
kind of data centered to data center
they would
just buy hardware encrypters and do that
between the data centers but again
no authentication although that's less
of a concern between data centers
much more of a concern going between
clouds or between data center and cloud
is that answer
yeah
it is yeah a huge thing with athens
because they are
generating certs um i think on an
eight-hour basis right
so
i don't
again the athens was not the part i was
super involved in uh
i don't think they were leveraging um
cloud specific services for that but i'm
not super sure on that
but yes that dealing with um
rapid certs not even from a cert
generation perspective but the bigger
issue is the distribution perspective
right
and with the secure edge 2 that's
something
our our
our server cert life cycle and my time
with yahoo went from like yeah maybe
once
a quarter or so we'll update all the
server certs to
three weeks and they're trying to grind
it down
so you know faster and faster and so to
do that you know once a quarter or so is
ops guys making sure everything's set up
correctly press the button open
but to do anything faster you have to
really do a lot of automation and that's
where
certainly
athens is a lot of automation and as i
said with the server cert distribution
too we're doing a lot more automation a
lot of
probing
our central central key central secret
server to fetch the information and
update things live without requiring
reboots and such
all right last call for questions
all right well thank you so much
and
reach out to me later if you have any
other questions thanks
[Music]
you